okay good morning can everybody hear me
right yeah I guess so
okay thank you many for interaction good
morning everyone I know I'm the last
thing between you and lunch so I'll try
to keep it light my name is Lucas I work
for booking.com I believe I am a
pragmatic data scientist and today what
I would like to do is to just share with
you some tricks and tools that I learn
in my experience I've been in the
industry for many years already and I
work with many people most of them are
better than me so I learned a lot from
them and I would like to share these
tricks and I really hope that you guys
like this tricks that you can use them
in your own projects and maybe you can
come up with your own tools and tricks
maybe even find some mistakes in my own
tricks that will be awesome
because that way I will round a bit so
let's get started the first thing I
would like to talk about is called KNN
from slow to fast thanks to math and the
idea is that you use this trick whenever
you are solving a Kenyans neighbor
problem so not sure if everybody saw or
what the this problem is about but just
just for the sake of argument let's say
that we have a set of documents these
are text documents and we want to
compute the most similar documents to
every document in the data set so
usually the way you solve this problem
is you somehow come up with the feature
vector for every document and this
feature vector is usually built using
the bag of force model so for every
document you will have a feature vector
the length of the double Cavalieri if
your data set and every component in the
vector will be the count of the words in
that particular document and this trick
will only work if you want to use cosine
similarity now of course there are many
similarity functions that you can use
but usually cosine similarity is a very
good choice and it's very important to
note that the the choice of the
similarity function has to be done with
respect to the data and not to any other
aspect so if you want to use cosine
similarity how do you solve this problem
well the straightforward solution is to
just compute if all the feature vectors
for for your documents and then whenever
you need to compute the K nearest
neighbor for a particular document X you
just compute the cosine distance from X
to every document sort and keep the last
K elements if you sorted by similarity
ascending okay that's a very good
solution because it works but if we take
a closer look we can analyze the
computational complexity of this
solution and we can see that there are
two parts in this algorithm first you
the easy part is when you sort this will
be analog n because you know sorting and
n is of course the amount of objects in
your data bytes in the rabbi's but
before certain you have to compute the
similarity against all the possible
documents and that will be in principle
linear but of course you have to take
into account every time you compute the
similarity you are the factor D which is
the dimension of your feature vector
which will be the length of their
vocabulary in this case so the total
complexity will be something that grows
like n log n plus something that grows
like nd and the thing is usually log n
will be much bigger than D suppose you
have 10 million documents then the Lord
will be something like 7 but D will be
for sure 10,000 so that's why in general
we say that this algorithm is linear in
both and undi now of course if you do
computational complexity analysis you
want to ask the question can we do
better and the usual ways to improve
this algorithm is probably using a hip
or maybe a quick select but none of this
will help because they will actually add
some some overhead now this the third
way to solve is to improve this is to
use a spice partition entry and that's
where I want to focus on this first the
space partition entry will work as an
index where you put your document
industry and then whenever you want to
compute the k-nearest neighbors say to a
document X you just read from the index
and dispersed partitioning tree will
make it in logarithmic time usually but
the problem is that we want to use cost
in similarity and conceal similarity is
not a metric because it doesn't hold the
triangular inequality and this is very
bad news because that means we cannot
use space partitioning trees at least
once I know they all require your your
distance function to be a metric so
that's not good so but here's some math
that we can try to use to improve this
or solve this problem so this is now
approved
it's sort of an a sketch and rub two
properties that we're gonna use one is
that consume distance is invariant under
normalization and what that means is
very simple if you have two vectors a
and B compute the cost in distance say
you get 0-5 now if you normalize a
normalized B and you compute the
consilience distance of the normalized
versions you still get 0-5 the number
doesn't change under normalization
because that exactly what cosine will do
with first normalize the vectors so
that's pretty simple the second property
is a little bit more OPAC and it says
that is a and B are unit vectors then
the Euclidean distance will be exactly 2
minus 2 cosine between a and B so this
is not that easy to see you can look up
the you keep in the wiki the proof but
what I want to focus is the fact that
you can already see that we are trying
to sort of relate cosine similarity to
clean distance and that's exactly what
the third line says is that if X is
closer to a is more similar to a than to
be in the Cassini's space then the
normalized version of X will be closer
to a normalized version of a than to a
normalized version of B I know this is a
little bit tongue twister but where with
me so the idea of the tricks to exploit
this
lemma here to actually end up using a
space partition entry so here's the
trick
just normalize all your feature vectors
and whenever of course you build a space
partition entry for example a KD tree
you put all the KD the 3d documents
indicated tree using a Lydian distance
remember that when we want to use cosine
but once we normalize the vector we can
use up Lydian which is a proper metric
so all good with the KD trees and
whenever we want to compute the K
nearest neighbors to X which is
normalized X and look up the KNN from
from the tree and this will be
logarithmic which is awesome and much
better than linear so I don't want you
guys to be convinced which is all this
math so what I did is I wrote some code
and run some experiments and this
wouldn't be a machine learning talk
without the amnesty data set in one
slide list so for the ones that don't
know this data set is just some
handwritten digits 70,000 pictures 28 by
28 pixels and the Pyxis goes from 0 to
255 so this is a form and this is how
the cosine similarity works so the first
column are the input pictures and the
all the other columns are the most
similar to the first in the same row so
in the first row you see many fours and
a 9 so there is a mistake there and the
second row you can see something I think
is it - this thing here honestly I don't
know
but the digressing believes is an 8 and
then a 7 and then the 9 so it's sort of
confused which makes sense because come
on this is it - I don't know but then it
doesn't make more mistakes all aids all
threes all fives all twos and you can
see that you know in in it it doesn't
only hits the deduction number but it
also captured some similarities in the
way the number is written for instance
the - all of them has the this loop and
there are many chooses which are more
like a seat but you know see any of
those are so it's actually
sort of competing similar
similarly written not only the same
digit so this is just to sort of justify
why I decided to use cosign and also to
show that you can sort of impress people
without using deep learning and so
here's the code I wrote this is premium
that I this design which is very simple
I use SK learn my favorite tool for
machine learning and there is nice very
nice implementation of I'm not saying
that because I'm dresses here no no so
you can use the nearest neighboring
implementation and is in the first
version I use metric equals cosine but
yeah this is very funny because cosine
is not a metric so but you need to use
of course brute force because that's the
only thing you can do if you try to pass
Beltre okay the trick here it will blow
up so that make sense versus another
version which is the trick version where
I just normalize all my data set first
and then I use soak Lydian with the ball
tree which which is one particular space
partitioning tree and now I want to
stress this these two solution are
exactly the same
there isn't any approximation so this is
computed with both solutions and this is
very important because usually for
getting some scale up factors you have
to pay with with the accuracy that's not
the case for this trick so results on
the x-axis you can see the data set size
which ranges from five thousand to forty
thousand and on the y-axis you can see
how long it took to compute the tap top
10 or top 9 most similar pictures for 20
pictures so there are two things to note
in this chart first of all oh sorry the
blue line is not rich at all so
consuming brute force the Green Line is
a space partitioning tree particularly
the KD tree and the red one is the
poultry okay so there are two or three
things to note here
one
that the blue line is a strain line so
that sort of supports our hypothesis
that the complexity of the problem is
linear in N which is important right
experiments validating what we computed
using math and the second thing to note
is of course that both Spurs
partitioning trees are much better than
the full scan solution and the third
thing to know maybe is that KD trees
little wars in Bowl tree honestly I'm
not sure why because the dimensionality
of this data set is not big so it
shouldn't be a problem so I was actually
expecting similar performance but okay
it's still bits the full scan which is
very good so that's all that's the first
trick moving on to the second
classification so bad data good math so
this trick you can use it whenever you
have a classifier and there are missing
features and your app at prediction time
so specifically you have a classifier
that predicts the probability of a class
conditioned on a set of features you
trans classifier all good but then a
prediction time there are missing
features an example of this in booking
for example not everybody
tell us whether they are doing a leisure
or business trip and then we like to
train our models using only people that
tell us what kind of trip they are
making but then when we with this train
model at prediction time we don't know
and we still need to make a prediction
we still want to recommend hotels so
this is a pretty frequent and of course
there are many ways to solve this
problem the more usual maybe is to use
the most common value the most frequent
value for the particular feature you can
use the spectral value you can use this
average in some neighborhood so similar
people do they do work or leisure and so
on so forth you can go all the way to nd
to end up building a machine learning
algorithm itself that will predict that
particular value but remember that
wasn't your initial goal so you mean see
you may
to think about it so let's look at this
a little closer first of all all these
solutions try to predict the value that
you want you that's missing right
there's nothing wrong with this but this
is just an observation about the most
usual approach some actually many of
them are not applicable for categorical
data what is the average between
business and leisure I don't know all
the solutions are very particular to
specific problems like using the average
in the neighborhood this is very useful
sometimes for pictures for image but in
general it's not applicable and finally
most of them are too naive too
simplistic or they take a long time or
an effort to build like a building
machine learning algorithm and also if
you can build a machine learning
algorithm that predicts this feature
then maybe you're better off using this
technology to improve your current
classifier so this is the analysis I
made about this problem but I would like
to propose a different way to look at
this problem which I call the
reductionism and the idea of
reductionism in the machine learning
field is to simply express a problem in
terms of problems that we know very well
already so in this case the reduction is
a direction is approach to this problem
I would simplify to only three features
so you have a classifier that opens the
probability of a class given feature a B
and C this will really have a classifier
that works will retrain it is awesome
but now we have the problem to compute
the probability of the class given only
feature a and C feature B is missing so
we want to reduce this problem that we
don't know how to solve to this other
problem that we already solved and
that's the approach that I propose and
for that we need some math not rocket
science I hope you guys are familiar
with the law of total probability which
allows us to express the probability of
a random variable as a marginalization
over some other random variable of our
choice
but maybe not
everybody will be that familiar with the
law of total conditional probability
which is sort of the same but we
condition on C right so the first law is
very straightforward there's nothing
obscure going on here but the second is
not like that because you have to assume
that the random variables B and C are
independent and this may be a very
strong assumption but this equation here
is what we're going to try to use to
solve the deduction to make so the
hughster trick is very simple so we have
the classifier already that opens a
probability given of a class given a
feature a B and C there might be some
examples where feature B is missing is
not specified and then in the trick we
assume that a feature a B and C they are
all independent actually for this
particular case we only need to assume
that feature B is independent from
feature a and C and then we estimate
this probability which is the problem
that we want to solve using this
equation that only needs this
probability that we already know how to
compute and of course it will need this
order probability that is very easy to
estimate from data so this is the trick
and I I know it's a little bit off track
so here's an example so suppose that we
want to compute the probability of
someone being happy going from one place
to another for a purpose now the purpose
can be work or vacation and sometimes it
will be missing now when we apply the
trick we assume that the purpose is
independent from the source of the
destination which is sort of okay I
guess right you can go from anywhere to
anywhere for both vacation and and and
working fish then the idea that you can
estimate so our problem is this estimate
this probability how likely the someone
will be happy going from Paris to Tokyo
and for that we're gonna use the
classifier that we already have that
give us the probability of me happy
parties Tokyo and work weighted by the
probability of work plus the same for
vacation so in this example all we're
doing is estimating this probability
using the model that we already built
and I think this is indeed very
pragmatic because you can build one
single classifier and then use it
whenever you want for independently of
how many or what features you're missing
okay once again I don't want to convince
you with math in slides so I wrote some
code and run some experiments again
handwritten digits but this time this is
a smaller problem then you you may tell
me why if you want we have only 64
pixels this time 70 possible values not
250 like the Emily's data set and you
will see that is a quite soon case
already so here's a procedure for to
show that this actually works I split
the tyrosine into train and test so I
have some pictures in the training data
in the training set array and some
pictures on the test set then I try the
multi-class logistic regression on the
training set using all possible pixels
all the 64 no missing data and then I
run let me remove D pixels
1 2 3 4 from the pictures in the test
set only and then I use the already
trained logistic regression on the train
set to try to try to predict the
contaminated test set and I compared
compared different approach approaches
so here the so oh this is a picture yeah
I think this is a 2 or an 8 I don't know
resolution is really low but the the
dark blue scores are like the background
the light blue squares are the ink and
the red ones are the things that I've
removed are the 3 pixels removed there
so here are the results on the x-axis
you have how many pixels were removed
from the test set on the y-axis is the
classification accuracy this is a pretty
balanced data set so accuracy is a
parametric and there are five lines the
black line is the baseline
so that one is actually tested again a
test set that is not contaminated at all
so that's the best we can do with that
particular classifier that you're
already trained the blue line which is
the worst is when you completely ignore
the problem you just don't know that
there are missing features and that what
happens is degrades pretty fast the red
is when you fill in every pixel with the
most likely value for that particular
pixel and the cyan which is this one
it's when you use the average which is
so similar now the Green is the trick
and as you can see it consistently
improves over all the other yeah because
I trained the test and training sets are
different for every one two three yeah
compare them right
why not it's the wrong random right yeah
so you could just feel okay no it's
right yeah I mean this is not the paper
like presentation right so of course I
should what I should do is sample many
times I'm probably true
I mean the action the actual complaint
will be there are not error bars yeah
they are okay so that's that's the those
are the results I got I run this many
times and I always get consistently the
code is available so if you want to wait
sort of three days to get this
confidence intervals built because you
can imagine that the this sum is over
all the possible combinations of all the
missing features and that's the catch
with this trick but we can discuss later
okay anyway I think it's a still a very
valid approach to try because it will
save you a lot of work you just use a
very simple question to solve a problem
that you didn't have with a solution
that you already have so that's about it
for this one and I have a last one
which is about the Scottish a
discritization it's all in the head
so the problem this one is a little bit
looser so we have data we have future
values and some particular values we
want to sort of group them into some
bins or clusters or groups so for
example the usual case is the age of a
person so you have a million of records
of people and you have ages from 0 to
110 right I don't know anybody living
more than that so maybe you want to sort
of group these ages because you believe
that if someone has zero one or two
years it's not the same they're growing
they're going from being a baby to a
child whereas if they have 73 74 75 sort
of the same so you want to find these
these groups of scalars and this is also
known as discritization being in
quantization 1d clustering you name it
right solutions are many I just name a
few here quantile meaning is probably
the most usual where you just take
standard deviations or percentiles
Jencks natural breaks it's also sort of
popular it turns out that is exactly the
same as doing k-means which is a very
popular class nihilism for one
dimensional data and then you have to
provide methods which are very very
interesting but this supervised methods
if when you find these groups for a
particular task you're solving a
classification task and you use a random
forest for decision trees then the
decision tree would try it will try to
find the groups of Ages for example that
maximize the probability of predicting
the class correctly so these are three
soft kind of solutions so one thing we
can say about this is that many methods
will take the amount of clusters and
input and this is very annoying
sometimes because you know I have ages
of people just I don't know how many
groups there will be so I have this is
usually a problem the second observation
has to provide methods are only suitable
for one specific task and sometimes it's
very funny because you will find stuff
like you know people with 34 years
they behave exactly the same as someone
with sixteen okay because but that's
because the data this group helps to
solve a particular task but then these
groups you cannot use them to understand
your problem better or to talk to people
or to pour these to some or some other
problem and also most methods are not
very robust to different distribution
types actually most of these methods
will assume that your data is pretty
symmetric if you have some skew in your
data set this method won't work very
well so what can we do well let's talk
about heavy-tailed data and it's very
difficult to express or define or find
the equations of heavy-tailed data so I
came up with some examples the most
common ones are for example the part the
power law where a variable is related to
another one X as a geometric function
the Pareto distribution is the same but
here the variable is particularly the
probability density of X and then this
is my favorite which is the right size
function where the value is actually a
power law with respect to its rank in
the list so if you take all the ages of
all the persons and you sort them by age
of course and then you plot age against
the run in the list then you get a power
law and then the log normal distribution
which has nothing to do with power loss
at all but it's also a heavy tail
distribution now there is a very nice
property of heavy tail distribution
which is that the mean which is usually
not very informative right if you have a
power law distribution the mean one tell
you anything it's not a very good
centrality estimator of the data but
it's very interesting that you can use
the mean to separate the values between
head and tail so we're going to use this
fact this property of heavy tailed data
to come up with the winds and the best
way I managed to explain this is with
also it does an example of
later here which is probably you have
already seen is the population of US
cities in 2009 so the x-axis is the rank
in the population rank of every
particular city and in the y-axis is the
population how many people live there
the blue line is exactly this and the
and the red line is the average so you
can see that all these cities are above
the average but all these others are not
so this is sort of an illustration of
this principle where the mean is split
in the data into head and tail there are
only 62 cities above the average and
about 2010 I think below the average and
it's very funny because this is exactly
21 79 which is very close to Pareto rule
so this is an illustration of this
principle and here's how we're gonna use
the trick so yeah
the best way to explain this trick is
with some code so you have data say a
list of ages and this is a list of rags
that we're gonna return so and it's just
how many data points we have and then we
compute the head as all the values that
are above the mean then we have the tail
which are all the values are below or
equal to the mean and then we append the
mean of the data to the breaks yeah I
know I computed the mean many times but
I just thought that it was more more
readable like this
now if the line of the head is left less
than 40% of the total data set then that
means that there is still heavy tail
data and we can continue doing this on
the head so this is a recursive call to
the head keeping the list of regs and we
continue like that until this condition
is no longer met which means the data
are now is symmetric and then we were
done that's it
so this is a logarithmic you can use to
compute bins on heavy tailed data
now again to convince you that this is
useful somehow even without confidence
intervals I designed this experiment in
which I used the Boston housing data set
from UCI this this data set has houses
with features and the price and the task
is to predict the price of the house
I usually narration as a baseline then I
apply Hetal brakes to every feature
because they are all continuous real
value features and then I discretize
them using the beans that I got from the
Hetal brakes trick and then a one hot in
code these beans and finally I use this
in the in the regression as a nonlinear
future so this is what the algorithm
found this is one of the features that
the best worked which is not very nice
to talk about but we copied a crime
right by town so luckily there are not
many houses located are places where the
crime is high just a few but there are
plenty where the crime is low now if you
are a bit little bit strict this is
actually a head torso tale because there
is also pretty dense in the middle but
the ordem actually works anyway because
pretty robust to this condition and
these are the pain started found so I
hope you can see the red line yeah it's
pretty clear which is the actual data
and then these are the beans so
everything between 0 and 3 is one
category everything which is 343 459
everything from 369 to 13 it's also a
category and so on so forth
this limit is it's not found by the
Edison I put it myself - Billie Sturm
but it will never the algorithm finds
this first than this than this and
finally 0 and the blue the blue squares
are a historama how many data points are
in every bin so one interesting thing to
note here is that if I'd
right I can tell you that the rail line
is actually as muscle version of the
histogram but this is not true the red
line is the actual data so it's very
funny to see how this algorithm is sort
of doing the inverse of smoothing and I
think that's a signal that the algorithm
will try to actually find very useful
pings and it's also very important to
note that the amount of beans is given
by as a response by the algorithm is not
the input so I didn't put a slide but I
did this for every feature and it's
found about for features which had this
same distribution and improve the score
the RMC score by a 6% more or less and
of course the reason is that we are
adding nonlinearities so the algorithm
is linear but if you add this pinning
then you get some non-linearity so
that's about it for tricks I just want
to say a few words about primary dress
and it's this talk I presented three
tricks but this talk is about primary
data science and if you want to become a
primary data science my recipe is to get
three basic skills math computer science
machine learning you can you cannot skip
any of these if you want to be a primary
data scientist and some values which are
experimentation like I show in the talk
everything I spoke about or is sort of
at least represented by experiments and
IO is one of my values that one
experiment is worth 1000 equations you
can write as many questions as you want
but if you have one successful
experiments that when you actually make
step forward in criticism is also a very
important value I know if you are
familiar with the no free lunch theorem
that says that for every item if it
works very well in one specific regime
in one specific condition for sure
there's another condition for which will
work really bad and that means that you
have to be very careful with these
tricks because for every trick there is
a trap and I didn't put the traps here
on purpose to see if we can talk about
them later on
see if you can find what are the traps
for every trick I expose here I
challenge you guys I think you found one
already and finally another value that I
suggest I propose is reductionism I
think this is very important to reduce
new problems - very well known and
studied problems and this is a very
philosophical of course thing but there
is actually a machine-learning field
called reductionism and i think john 9:4
which is the main contributors wobb wobb
it is one of the main researches in this
area and Wolper worried in itself is
using a lot of reductionism
to solve the problems and I think this
is a very interesting approach to
engineering and there are science and I
think these six things are key elements
to be a primary there are scientists
that's all I want to thank Sammy's my
buddies here for helping me with the
code also published errors he's not
around
Melanie Muller for helping me with the
slides also and also this tricks and
some more are available in my github in
that URL please don't look at the other
projects are not very good that's all I
guess Thanks
questions I thank you very much for the
talk it was really useful I was thinking
on the on the second trick when you were
inputting the missing values yeah I was
thinking yeah this one I was thinking in
the in the digit recognition
you also have values that are missing
but in your problem I was guessing like
I don't know coming for example to this
conference is it less sure is it work I
don't know if missing values could could
be considered a different category in
this case so I'm not sure if you if you
check that just assuming that it's like
authors modem yeah yeah absolutely
that's a that's a that's a thing to look
into and it depends on every problem and
missing value is a missing value if you
if you really think that is information
in the fact that the value is missing
then you should definitely use it as a
feature but this you should check
beforehand right so when you build the
classifier you will check correlation
between the no value and the class or
whatever output you want to predict and
if this no value helps you with the
classifier then you should keep it but
it doesn't you shouldn't keep it you
should remove it and if you remove it
then in prediction time you don't have
this capability right so if you keep it
only to be able to make a prediction you
actually hurting your algorithm just to
be able to make a prediction when the
value is missing so you should only keep
the no value when the sigh well that
actually adds information to your
predictor
hi thanks for the talk and about your
your first trick they went about
normalization and clothing yeah and it
is for using cases when you have the
vector some help renormalized because
from what I see you have to normalize
and vectors of dimension D yeah so the
normalization face it's o of n D I think
oh yes of course
so this is yeah that's C that's a good
catch that's part of the traps when you
fit the model I didn't put here Sammy's
Ryan wanted me to put this light when
you fit the model sorry where is it here
this does nothing right but this one
will build the KD tree and this will
take a lot of time so you pay the cost
at the beginning but only once so that's
up to you whether this is depends on the
problem yeah yeah but that's definitely
a trap
so for the second trick in your
application is the independence
assumption actually true how do check so
yeah I would I would imagine that like
more people go to work to like a big
city into the beach 400 for that
particular you mean yeah oh yeah no
that's for sure not yeah we know for
sure not yeah so but then one way around
the independence assumption would be to
sort of not impute the label but build
the probability model right you can like
trainer model like a lot of district
regression or whatever to get that get
the distribution conditional
distributions and that it probably would
work better right yeah that was
something like this yeah
in did I not predict my future I already
use reliability you use this exactly
yeah yeah that's we yeah I should have
probably done that but for that you need
to build a new classifier and what if
you have missing value from that's like
so if you start doing that you end up
building in your network by hand right
probabilities layers probabilities but
it is absolutely a good approach this is
just a very general approach this is my
point with this no okay all right I want
to do the same some I would go through
the next slide okay okay I didn't get it
in yeah this one I want to build
classifier that predicts PR of be given
yeah I get given C and I built it like a
logistic regression is in condition here
if you condition here you're breaking
everything right no oh no no you're
right
so I understand you conditioning and I
do the conditioning you know the model
for the conditional probability yeah
your Swiss marching along mine but you
didn't build it thought experiments
don't have results remember nobody's is
of course a very good yeah it's a very
good so you you guys I hope you guys
follow so we are conditioning everything
on C and here I should also conditioned
on C but I drop it using this in the
independence assumption so INRIA says is
while right on Belinda which is keep the
conditioning and then we build an
armature
learning to predict to compute or it
will be an estimator of that particular
probably that's indeed a very good idea
more questions someone wants to point
out another trap
okay let's thank Lucas again